[Musique]
oui
pas une fois je me suis même tordu la
cheville a pas une fois à partir de
maintenant je ne doit plus être le seul
à connaître la formule de la potion
magique où je mets donc partir à la
recherche d'un jeune successeur à qui il
a confié coin catastrophe qui sait ce
qui se passerait si la puissance de la
potion magique tomber dans n'importe
quelles mains d'un homme
avez-vous en tête la liste des jeunes
truites gaulois bien côté je raconte des
petites fiches des critiques la petite
fille cette maison habitable double et
érable j'ai des super dur cela ils sont
pas enfuis su le faire une soupe à
l'oignon
ici les mauvais mais qui arrive quand
même à bricoler deux trois trucs on me
surnomme humanité
et là les réponses
tu vas y mollo sur la frime quand même
ave caesar de cette caution je te le
donnerai à potion des dargaud quelle est
cette manigance sulfurique ce ce soir
c'est la fin du vinage de crétins
moustachu la fin d'acte ericsson je
verse salade dans du porc un druide vois
pas pourquoi ce serait plus dur que
d'être pas soigné
d'être mené
jekel pas bu tu peux taper pourquoi
tombe ça tu sais mieux que ça fait
chaque fois j'ai modifié à 10 sa part
exposé c'est que c'est bon ça explosera
plus près
si tu es aussi bon droit que poissonnier
va y avoir de la performance alors
qu'est ce qu'il raconte dans ses
remarques à quel âge tu veux faire le
show du tout
bah oui c'est fini oh non mais je pense
que je devais être sur la fin fins